تحول الى جباليه حيث افاد مراسل الجزيره
باشتباكات بين المقاومه وقوات الاحتلال في
جباليه البلد ومعنا من مخيم جباليه شمالي
غزه الصحفي عماد زقوت عماد قربنا من صوره
الاوضاع الان وحده هذه الاشتباكات المندلع
بين قوات المقاومه والجيش
الاسرائيلي نعم على مدار الساعات الماضيه
تحديدا في الساعه الاولى من الليله
الماضيه حتى هذه اللحظه هنالك اشتباك
ضاريه جدا في منطقه جباليا البلد وجباليا
النزله هنالك الاشتباكات شديده جدا نستمع
اليها بشكل واضح وكذلك يتخلل هذه
الاشتباكات تفجيرات قويه جدا هذ على مدار
الساعات الاخيره ربما اخر خمس ساعات من
الان وهذه الاشتباكات هي اشتباكات متواصله
ومستمره هنالك اشتباكات ضاريه في هذه
المنطقه بالتحديد في منطقه جباليه البلد
على مستوى كذلك عدد الشهداء هنالك ايضا
الاليات العسكريه الاسرائيليه تحاصر الاف
المواطنين في منطقه جبل البلد حيث مدارس
التي ينزح اليها عدد كبير من المواطنين
الان هم محاصرون بفعل تواجد هذه الاليات
العسكريه الاسرائيليه هنالك تخوف على حياه
هؤلاء النازحين في هذه المدارس بعد هذه
الاشتباكات الضاريه والقويه بين المقاومه
الفلسطينيه وبين الاليات العسكريه
الاسرائيليه عدد الشهداء ربما يتجاوز خلال
الايام الاخير وهو لا يوجد احصائيه رسميه
لعدم لخروج المستشفيات في شمال قطاع غزه
عن الخدمه لان هنالك حسب المتابعه
ومتابعه الاحداث الميدانيه من قبلنا هنالك
ربما يكون اكثر من 400 شهيد خلال الايام
الاخيره في مناطق جباليا البلد والنزله
ومنطقه الجرن وفي مخيم جباليا وكذلك عند
انسحاب الاليات العسكريه من مناطق تل
الزعتر ومنطقه مشروع بيت لاهيه ومناطق
دوار زايد ومنطقه زايد
والاندونيسي وجدنا عديد الشهداء ملقون على
الارض هنالك عشرات الشهداء وجدناهم في هذه
المنط المناطق ملقون على الارض و وقد
وجدنا العديد من هذ هؤلاء الشهداء وقد
تحللت اجسادهم بسبب وجودهم لفترات زمنيه
طويله بفعل تواجد الالات العسكريه التي
كانت تمنع سيارات الاسعاف من التوجه الى
هذه المناطق من شده الغارات الاسرائيليه
وكذلك استهداف من قبل القناصه
الاسرائيليين انا اتواجد الان في هذه
المناطق
واجد حجم الدمار الى حتى هذه اللحظه
والمدفعيه الاسرائيليه تقصف في هذه
المناطق وكذلك هنالك نستمع الى هذه
الاشتباكات الضاريه جدا بين المقاومه
الفلسطينيه وبين الاليات العسكريه التي
ايضا لم نستمع لها من قبل هي اشتباكات
واضحه انها اشتباكات ضاريه اشتباكات قويه
جدا تستخدم فيها مختلف الاسلحه المتوفره
سواء للمقاومه الفلسطين الصينيه تحديدا
كتائب القسام وسراي القدس وايضا كذلك
الاليات العسكريه تقصف بقداه والمدفعيه
الاسرائيليه تقصف والطائرات المسيره تقصف
وكذلك الطائرات الحربيه تتدخل بين الحين
والاخر هنالك حاله من ساحه القتال
الحقيقيه في هذه المنطقه في منطقه جباليه
البلد وايضا الى الشرق من مخيم جبالي حيث
تواجد ايضا الاليات العسكريه هنالك اشتباك
مع هذه الاليات العسكريه و استهدافات
للاليات الموجوده من قبل المقاومه
الفلسطينيه الوضع المعيش هنا الوضع هنا
وضع صعب توجه المواطنون الى المناطق التي
انسحبت منها الاليات العسكريه وجدوا حاله
من الدمار حاله من الخراب الاليات تعمدت
ان تدمر كل شيء وتخرب كل شيء البنى
التحتيه ومنازل المواطنين وكل ما يتعلق
بحياه الناس هنا مدمره بفعل هذه الاليات
العسكريه الاسرائيل التي كانت تبني
لنفسها سواتر من منازل المواطنين وسواتر
رمليه وسواتر من الشاحنات الكبيره هي ايضا
كانت تتخوف من المقاومين الفلسطينيين
وكانت بتواجدها ايضا كانت هي خائفه جدا
واضحا الخوف
و الادويه والعلاجات لجنود الاحتلال سواء
في منازل المواطنين او في بعض الشوارع
بجراء الاصابات من بفعل المواجهه مع
المقاومه الفلسطينيه اذا هذه الحاله
الموجوده الان في شمال قطع عماد بالمقارنه
مع الايام ومعارك الايام الماضيه هل رصدت
اي اختلاف في مسار المعارك وضرتها وخطوط
تماسها كذلك في
جبيه انت تتحدثين وال هنالك تفجيرات قويه
في هذه المناطق
جرا هي الطائرات المسيره تحلق بارتفاعات
منخفضه الان ما زالت هذه التفجيرات هي
مستمره العديد من التفجيرات في كل مكان من
الجنوب ومن الشرق ومن الغرب ما زالت
وطائرات المسيره هي تحلق بكثافه وه ايضا
تطلق القذائف فيها وهذه الاشتباكات يعني
تضرب في كل مكان هنا في شمال قطع غزه في
جباليا وفي جباليا المعسكر ما زالت
تفجيرات وما زالت القذائف وربما هذا ناتج
عن الاشتباكات الضاريه بين المقاومه
الفلسطينيه وبين هذه الاليات العسكريه
التي على مدار ال اليومين الماضيين وهي
تتقدم تجاه جباليا البلد تفجيرات قويه
قويه جدا ناتجه عن هذه هذه المدفعيه وهذه
التفجيرات من الديات العسكريه الاسرائيليه
تفجيرات كبيره وقويه في كل مكان ربما
تستمعون الى هذه التفجيرات وه هذه
الانفجارات التي نستمع لها بشكل واضح ونحن
هنا في الميدان في هذه المنطقه تحديدا في
منطقه الشمال ومخيم جباليا ايضا ارى
واشاهد الناس بالمئات يتوجهون الى منازلهم
التي انسحبت منها الاليات العسكريه والكل
هنا يبحث عن احبابه وعن حاجياته في ظل هذه
الغارات الاسرائيليه المكثفه والتفجيرات
التي هي مستمره على مضار الساعه لم تسكت
ولم تهدا هنالك كذلك الليله الماضيه حتى
الساعات الاولى من الفجر كانت التفجيرات
ايضا مستمره وقويه بفعل المقاومه
الفلسطينيه التي تواجه هذه الاليات
العسكريه هذه الاليات العسكريه عندما تفشل
في مواجهه المقاومه الفلسطينيه فانها تتجه
الى
استهداف المناطق السكانيه ومنازل
المواطنين هنالك تخوف من الاهالي على
ابنائهم المتواجدين في مدارس الواء في
منطقه جبال البلد خوفا من اقتحام هذه
المدارس واعتقال من فيها وقتل من فيها
وجدنا حالات اعدامات ميدانيه من قبل
الاليات العسكريه التي كانت تتواجد في
منطقه تل الزعتر وكذلك في مشروع بيتلا
والشيخ زايد ومحيط مستشفى الاندونيسي
وجدنا حاله اعدامات ميدانيه من جنود
الاحتلال لمواطنين فلسطينيين هذه ايضا
الاعتقالات الفلسطينيه بحق المواطنين
الفلسطينيين الاهالي لا يعلمون شيئا عن
ابنائهم الصليب الاحمر لا يستجيب لهم لا
يتواصل معهم هنالك تخوف ايضا على
المعتقلين الفلسطينيين التفجيرات ما زالت
مستمره ومتواصله في كل مناك المواقع
تحديدا في الجنوب الى مخيم جباليا ومنطقه
جبال البلد والى الغرب منها والى الشرق
منهاج
ماز ونستمع ال الى اصوات الانفجارات وانت
حدثتنا ونقلت لنا اخبار الاشتباكات كذلك
الملعه في هذه الاثناء في جباليه اشكرك
جزيل الشكر من مخيم جبليه شمالي غزه
الصحفي عماد زقوت